Gene, look, this piece is
totally slanted...
it lacks in-depth reporting,
it has no sources...
and it makes outrageous claims.
It's what we in the news world
like to call... perfect.
Oh, my gosh.
Thought you were gonna go a
different way with that. Wow!
Thank you! I felt really
good about it.
Like a regular Barb Walters.
So you wanna just give me
my press badge...
and I'll head off
to the big match?
Yeah, unfortunately I can't
do that.
What's up?
Your GPA... it's too low.
Your exam grades were posted.
What? She failed me...
and passed Matt!
Oh, that bitch!
Hi, Gene, I can't talk
right now.
Oh, are you in a hurry, on the
way to the big match?
Yeah, actually, I am.
Oh, that bitch!
What?
You posted our grades online,
Billie!
I saw that you passed Matt,
even though he failed.
How did you know--
Because I let him copy off of me
and he passed and I failed!
And now I can't be the
Bob Costas of the school...
because my GPA is so low.
And it's all your fault,
you stupid bitch!
Roxie, play death metal.
Gene, wait! Stop circling me,
Gene, I am going to tell them!
Will you shut off your
dance club music? Thank you.
Look, I know what I did was
wrong.
I'm going right now to tell
the truth! Will you--
Roxie, play death metal!
I'm going to tell the truth!
Will you turn that off!
Gene, would you turn that off,
please!
I'm sorry, I couldn't hear you.
What?
I said I'm going right now...
Yeah?
...to stop it.
I'm going to tell the coach...
Roxie, death metal!
...and the dean that he failed.
Will you stop being such a baby!
Oh, I'm a baby?
You had no problem failing
this baby, did you, Billie?
That's because I expect more
from you, Gene!
Plus, you let him cheat!
Me cheats?
Yeah, you cheats.
You cheat, sweets.
Yeah, you cheat, sweets.
You cheat!
Eat sweet-- take cheats!
You cheat! Sweep streets!
Hey, give me that.
Give me that, Hand!
This is the only thing I
learned...
No!
...in your stupid class, Billie!
The joust!
No! No! Stop!
This isn't fair, your Rascal's
way faster than mine!
Oh, yeah, you're right,
I'll handicap myself.
No, you have a metal flag pole!
This is crazy!
Hey, you! Gimme this!
Hey, that's my hand, man.
Relax, Shane, I'll give it back.
Do you guys not have anything
more battle-worthy than a--
Never mind.
How do you know my name?
You're in my class, you idiot!
You have very sweaty hands.
Live fast, die slow, bitch!
That doesn't make any sense,
bitch!
I need my flag.
Agh!